you worked with Joe Rogan when you were
young right when you were younger do you
guys both start in Boston yeah we both
started in Boston at the clubs and he
was like a handsomest guy remember yes
he was yeah I mean he was still a
handsome guy right I loved her and uh
but how was there any like because now
if you're like a handsome comedian
people are like oh [ __ ] this guy right
you can't have it all no handsome
doesn't help you on stage yeah was it
like were people like that against like
whenever he was starting out well I
remember when he I was I started maybe a
couple years before him so I was
starting to feel like you know
established or in that little Boston
scene
and then this guy he started with guys
like Greg Fitzsimmons and him yeah
they're still really close yeah and
there was a few other guys Robbie Prince
he might have been after
but these guys were like new they're the
First new guys I was aware of oh yeah
I'd been a new guy for a couple of years
and so now these were new guys to me so
I was probably threatened by them
whatever but I do remember feel like
Greg Greg was a you know he's an Irish
kind of like he's not as handsome no
he's not no yeah but not back then he
was more handsome yeah Greg's like a
bookie [ __ ] like cousin yeah
exactly yes but uh Joe
it wasn't just his looks it was just he
had this confidence yeah and he's from I
we grew up in the same town I'm from
Newton Massachusetts he grew up there
too okay so I went to Newton North High
School and he went to Newton South both
Public Schools but his was kind of
fancier they were like kind of richer
because I kind of thought of him as this
like Newton South
he was so tanned oh he looked the dude
looks great yeah and he was just like
dude like he didn't he didn't talk like
a comic
he talked about [ __ ] chicks and he
talked about being getting being hot and
getting laid or whatever and he and uh I
could see that he had a power on stage
but yeah I was threatened by him because
he was like a good looking guy a couple
years younger than me started after me
yeah who was getting some attention yeah
and uh so on stage I would be like what
is what's what's for this guy but he was
also
interesting as a guy and not typical
some guys who are handsome are trapped
by that you know
but he was an interesting dude and then
when he went on and and I'd hear his
stand up I I was like that's he's
working and he's good and I liked his
stand-up
um and then he we had kind of across
roads thing because he did that thing
with Carlos Mencia where he outed him
first oh yeah which however you feel
about that but that it was his he was
very he was adamantly about it and then
his agency Gersh told him if you don't
dump uh if you don't stop if you don't
apologize to Carlos
will dump you and that was my agency was
Gersh
and so he let them go and I heard that
and I was like that's crazy and I called
him and we didn't we hadn't talked in a
long time but I contacted him to say I
need to hear from you if that's a true
story and he said 100 wow they called me
and they said apologize or you're out of
the agency and that's all I needed to
hear I called them and I said uh you're
not my agents anymore what if I have an
argument with another comedian what are
you [ __ ] nuts yeah you can't do that
so I dumped them and then I got started
to know that side of Joe
that's like he believes what he believes
and he goes by it whether it's going to
hurt him or not
and I've always known him that way we
just would run our friendship has been
like running into each other in the
parking lot of this Comedy Store and
talking for a couple hours about life
and it's most comedians yeah yeah yeah
people always ask what he's like he's
one of the most generally curious guys I
ever yeah like he has like any of that
he just retains information so well and
people are always like well you a lot of
you podcaster guys you guys suck Rogan's
dick you know that kind of stuff you
like him number one yeah and he's good
at it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one